Das hat es noch nicht gegeben die gesamte nordhalbkugel der erde ist überhitzt und jetzt bestätigt deutschlands bekanntester
klimaforscher ja das sind die folgen des klimawandels und das ist wirklich eine wende denn damit waren klimaexperten bisher sehr sehr
vorsichtig und es wird immer schlimmer krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja es wird immer schlimmer eigentlich so ein satz den man als journalist nicht verwendet aber hier trifft er zu
100 prozent so in deutschland ist im moment eine wahre
dürrekatastrophe im gange die ernte gegen stark zurück und in den nächsten wochen ist nicht mit einer abkühlung zu rechnen und hier in deutschland
das ist keine ausnahme die gesamte nordhalbkugel
ist überhitzt wir haben ja darüber berichten zu den waldbränden in schweden kamen jetzt weitere verheerende
feuersbrünste in griechenland dazu mindestens 80 menschen starben dort in den flammen und auch hier in deutschland
brennt es inzwischen und das sind aus der perspektive der natur eigentlich keine außergewöhnlichen katastrophen ist brennt einfach wenn es heiß wird
dass es schlicht und einfach
unvermeidlich und wir sind schlecht
vorbereitet hier in westeuropa gibt es einfach zu wenig oder keine löschflugzeuge und jetzt schlagen auch man muss sagen endlich die
klimaforscher alarm aus der abstrakten gefahr wurde dieses jahr eine reale die aktuelle hitzewelle ist laut
motiv
außergewöhnlich weil sie schon so lange anhält es bestätige sich mehr und mehr was wir klimaforscher lange
vorausgesagt haben und zwar mit blick auf den klimawandel in deutschland sagte der meteorologe und professor am kieler helmholtz-zentrum für ozeanforschung
der passauer neuen presse damit hängt er sich erstmals sehr konkret aus dem fenster was er bisher bei konkreten
wetterereignissen immer vermieden hat jetzt ist der klimawandel aber wirklich nicht mehr bei diesem ausmaß der veränderung zu verleugnen
zitat seit beginn der messung hat sich die durchschnittliche temperatur um
14 grad erhöht das ist mehr als im globalen durchschnitt so latif die
sommerhitze nimmt zu wir erleben immer mehr hitzetage mit 30 grad oder mehr zugleich nimmt die zahl der tropennächte
zu in denen die temperatur nicht mehr unter 20 grad fällt
und jetzt wird es noch wärmer hierfür berlin werden 36 grad und mehr erwartet es wird einfach
sehr sehr heißt das haben wir schon in der vergangenheit
ich erinnere nur an den sommer 2003 aber noch nie so lange und noch nie so
flächendeckend kurzfristig dass sich diese entwicklung nicht aufhalten meint der glieder kieler klimaforscher und kritisiert die
internationale politik tut zu wenig steuert nicht konsequent um der weltweite co2 ausstoß steigt immer weiter an die erderwärmung
nimmt immer weiter zu auch die bundesregierung tue zu wenig und wird ihrer verantwortung nicht gerecht so habe beispielsweise die automobilindustrie
die selbstverpflichtung zum klimaschutz und zum schadstoffausstoß nie
eingehalten lag hier weiter diese kurzfristigen wirtschaftlichen interessen dominieren die
langfristigen interessen der umwelt und des landes je länger wir zögern und nichts tun desto gefährlicher
würdest und dass es jetzt schon gefährlich wird das ist jetzt auch schon klar 2003 dauerte die hitzewelle 14 tage sie kostete geschätzt
70.000 menschen das leben und verursachte einen riesigen wirtschaftlichen
schaden von wahrscheinlich mehr als zehn milliarden euro sie war damit die opfer reiche
naturkatastrophe seit 40 jahren eine der schwersten naturkatastrophen in europa seit 100 jahren und das tödlichste
wetterereignis überhaupt in der geschichte der menschheit von dem wir zuverlässig wissen
dieses jahr wird es wohl stimmen wenn er kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp
dann umgeht er naja die leicht
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube und ihr verpasst kann wie du mehr denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
stimmblöcke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
klimawandel bestätigt skeptiker endgültig widerlegt bis dann
bleibt dran